this man all the way to back I'm
Caroline and how are you so I look I'm
very interested in the wine world and I
personally think it's one of the most
romantic markets out there it's the best
for stories and the best probably the
longest journey out there so where do
you see wine going in the u.s. I can
speak to the US I'm asking apologize I
just don't know the markets outside the
US as well why is it really to spawn
America um you know we're past the
douchey phase you know 1970s 80's 90's
did you drank wine you reduce right and
so you were fancy your snobby right and
then everybody else frankly Centinela
box wine
there was just no middle class and the
middle class start merging in the mid
90s and then the Wine Spectator Robert
Parker became the engines that throw a
wall of wine and then look I'm very
proud I think one of the most proud
things I'll have in my legacy is there
will be that Wikipedia entry of when I
started with Wine Library TV because
when I started with Wine Library TV
became the preview to what was about to
happen in the world wine world which is
we live in an incredible democracy of
wine now for 15 years the white
spectator Robert Harper basically
dictated what everybody was drinking in
America that cared enough to care about
wine and now we're at a place where
people are trying new things in America
as of ten years ago mainly drank six or
seven or eight different varietals and
and then a movie came out we drank Peter
the water that made at 9:00 right so
like you know people weren't drinking
different things I think that it blows
me up like I grew up in the wine
business and I tried to get my 21 22 23
24 year-old threads in the mid 90s late
nineties to get into why do they have no
interest it blows my mind the interest
in wine for the 21 to 30 year olds
sector we're taking different wines from
different parts of the world the quality
of wine is greater than ever because of
technology about knowing weather
conditions so I mean used to be able to
buy a really crappy bottle of wine
for ten bucks no joke it's getting hard
you may not like it but to get a bad
bottle of wine for ten bucks is getting
hard you know with Argentinian bow back
and New Zealand something Blanc and like
all these things so I'm very bullish on
I actually missed the wine business
quite a bit lately this is like a new
thing for me in the last I'm gonna get
an every day of my life from 15 to 35 so
I was burned out when I decided to start
doing the agency with my brother and
investing and other things I find myself
gravitating back to it I've got some
things in my mind of getting a little
bit deeper back into it and so I think
it's a great time for mowgli's got to
tell me you're done well because because
it is such a shared experience and
beautiful open a bottle and want to feel
the story do you see that changing a lot
maybe more of a personal experience I do
think some people drink wine by
themselves no I think that's what's
great about wine wine is it's why it was
such a good business for me I'm a
storyteller and boy does wine allow you
to story tell I mean I used to I was in
this kinda learn my craft in the store I
learned that everybody in here much
rather me tell you about the golden
retriever that ran around the vineyards
and ate the grapes and how many
percentage of sugar was in the wine got
it and so that's why my show did so well
right like I was able to tell stories
about the wines I was drinking and so
now I think that never goes away I think
- I like to think that wine was the
original social network you know it
brings people together
it is a beverage that is drank with more
than one person more than the urine and
vodka but and liquor by percentage and
so you know I think it's got a very
great feature of being a connector and I
do think you know look Tennessee has
this state like you guys are at the
disservice of Tennessee laws around wide
shipping so this state is behind a lot
of other places even smaller states less
progressive states because the loss
right because great wine companies like
my company wasn't
you ship here for a long time with Tana
exact nature but you know I don't know
if your time people spend outside but
it's incredible whether rural Southwest
Northwest just wine culture is exploding